I always remember saying to my dad he
was he was quite astonished at how
brutal I'd become I said I've read
somewhere that you can drink Turtle
blood you should catch one of these and
drink its blood
a third Turtle came along
and uh I wrapped it up in the in the
lifeline there was a Lifeline attached
to the raft and then we towed him around
to the dinghy hold him on board doogle
did that and cut his throat
and
drank his blood
we cut his shallow
and he was full she was full of red meat
like steak
and eggs
full of eggs and we realized there's a
food source there that we could probably
live off
and all we needed was more Turtles
but for now we drank the blood of this
turtle and we knew that then
that we perhaps for the first time
stood a chance of surviving